-Today is Friday,
and that's usually when I
catch up with some
personal stuff.
You know, I check my inbox,
I return emails and,
of course, I send out
thank you notes.
And I was --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
I love you guys.
I was running a bit behind
today, so I thought
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd just like to write out
my weekly thank you notes
right now.
I appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
The best audience
in the business.
James, can I get some thank you
note writing music, please?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
He's like a "Mona Lisa."
I don't know
if he's happy or upset.
-Mystic, mystic smile.
-Mmm.
-Thank you, "Eternals,"
or as I like to call you,
designer Power Rangers.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, Jack-O-Lantern
for always being way scarier
the first week of November
than you ever were on Halloween.
What the heck is that thing?
Get it off!
Get it!
You take it off the porch!
I don't want to touch it."
-Get a dust pan.
-Get a shovel.
Something, man.
Thank you, McDonald's,
selling an McRib NFT
for combining a mysterious
object no one understands
with a mysterious object
no one understands.
[ Laughter and applause ]
So meta.
Thank you, Adele's new song
"I Drink Wine..."
[ Cheering ]
...for finally giving
millennials there very own
"Margaritaville."
It's our anthem!
Come on!
[ Applause ]
Thank you, staple removers,
for looking like
the rattlesnakes
of Office Depot.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you, leaf peeping,
for basically being
bird watching for people who are
terrible at finding birds.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Leaf peeper.
Sure, if it makes you happy.
Come on.
Thank you, microwave
add 30 seconds button,
for rendering
every other button
on my microwave completely
and totally obsolete.
Pop, pop, pop, pop, pop popcorn!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-30 minutes?
-Pop, pop, pop, pop, popcorn!
-Pow, pow.
-That's what I'm like
when I go gambling.
-Yeah.
-Jimmy Popcorn here.
-Every time you're at the craps
table you just yell,
"Popcorn!"
-Yeah I go...
[ Rattling ]
Popcorn!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's it. Worth it.
No, no.
Popcorn! Yeah, yeah.
I gotta remember that.
I love Vegas.
I'll go there next time
and I'll do, "Popcorn."
-What's that?
-I'm going to Vegas --
-Yeah, let me know when you go.
I wanna go.
-What's that?
-Let me know when you go.
-Okay.
-Not before.
-Wait until you go,
then tell me after,
we'll talk about it.
-So when I'm there
I should tell you.
-Mnh-mnh.
When you come back home.
-Okay.
-I'll wait for it.
-Yeah, I'll wait, don't worry.
It's gonna be great.
-I can't wait.
-For me to go to Vegas?
[ Laughter ]
-I can't even talk about it now.
-Why?
You got something to do?
-Yeah.
-What's that?
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to do this bit.
I'm going to finish this bit.
-Oh, I'm sorry.
You were doing a bit.
I did not realize it.
Zip, zip,
shutting it up.
Go for it.
Don't want to interrupt it.
-No.
[ Laughter ]
It's humor. The people --
the people enjoy it.
Got to show some respect.
-You gotta respect comedy.
-You've got to show it
the respect.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you, getting into a car
while holding a pizza box,
for making me feel like
I'm playing
a game of human "Tetris."
[ Applause ]
-Popcorn!
-Oh!
-[ Laughs ]
Wait, this is the last one?
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you,
two-door refrigerators,
for making it look like my
condiments are flashing me.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my "Thank You Notes."